let me add before the prayer that we are
greatly humbled by so many newer
billions and those from other places
from other faith communities who have
come here today to witness the ceremony
we are honored by your presence we
apologize for any confusion that might
have occurred there was no offense meant
by that and we pray that you maintain
the and appreciate the spirit the
gravity to the Magdi the awesomeness of
this moment bismillah hamdulillah
greetings of peace salaam alaikum you
know this week we're talking about the
muslim american hero
Muhammad Ali does this week's show and
subhanAllah the Creator the heavier of a
law works in incredible ways we were
showing and highlighting some of the
Champs life and you saw the janazah o
I guess who's here with me on my left
the person who was actually old friend
share who we go way back and he was the
one who was actually leading the janazah
you gestured che salam alayka
rahmatullah wa barakato
yeah i'm here with old friend we go back
i'll be 13 years or so we filmed the
show a long time ago probably most of
you don't remember that didn't catch it
and we were together in Orange County in
California once and in fact one of
Eddie's good friends took Shahada at
that time one of his Chinese mentees and
martial arts so I'm duelin I'm here in
this beautiful bucolic country setting
this is it brothers and sisters if you
live in the city has its advantages
which you have to get out to the country
from time to time to breathe fresh air
walk around on your bare and your bare
feet get grounded grounding or what's
called earthing the concept is that when
we're literally in touch with the earth
we absorb electrons that help neutralize
the free radicals in our body that
damage our cells birthings proponents
say this grounding can reduce
inflammation pain and stress if you're
grounded
your blood is flowing as long as you
stay grounded and it also thins the
blood so you're less likely to have a
heart attack and stroke in fact the
thins the blood so much that if you're
taking a blood thinner you have to lower
the dose that's the power of grounding
the grounding is so critical for your
brain it causes instantaneous changes in
your left feet of left brain to right
it's where the right brain what's going
on there
that's the creative side the left brain
that's analytical side as soon as you
ground yourself your left brain goes to
powers down right brain doesn't change
but your left brain does is it helps to
enhance circulation so with increased
circulation now you have more energy you
have more nutrients you're carrying the
way more wastes so that has a tremendous
positive effect on the body improve
sleep
another major benefit according to the
earthing research nowadays they're
finding out that connecting your body to
the earth many people are doing this now
by walking look look just barefoot just
connecting your your body to the earth
releases these electrostatic charges
that develop in the body and this can
also cause headaches neck aches muscle
spasms a new research is showing that a
lot of good science to point out people
who ground sleep better have lower
inflammation and feel better throughout
the day have a better mood just by
grounding or earthing you can release
these electro static charges this is
amazing because we do this five times a
day in select yeah a you Molina a man
who cows judo boudoir Beckham or boudoir
Beckham wastrel on fire a Lancome to
flee
we take our forehead and we ground
ourselves we ground ourselves in such de
insula walk around on your bare and your
bare feet get grounded with the earth
connect to the earth that alot are
displaced and spread out for us smell
the smells of the farm the natural
smells of life and vitality
so I hum Dalila I'm blessed to be here
and hum do you like this all I can say
shake tell us what was it about Muhammad
Ali I've been so many boxers they've
just you know in the boxing community
they might be known but they've been
forgotten what why are people why be
people been so taken by him that you
know he's been a household name for so
many years and you actually got to lead
his funeral prayer on Allah no Muhammad
Ali is the people's champ and he became
the peoples champ not just based on what
he did in the ring what he did in the
ring provided him the platform he's the
heavyweight champion of the world he's a
young charismatic energetic figure who
comes a long handsome good-looking
figure that comes along right at the
time that television begins to mature as
a medium and the the mid 60s going into
the late 60s so here is Ali he's teller
made for this medium in terms of his
charisma terms of his looks in terms of
his stature as heavyweight champion of
the world and then he gives it all up
how can you do my pose a lot on freedom
you my opposer when I want justice you
might fall zombie father you won't even
stand up for me
for my religious beliefs and you want me
to go somewhere fight but you want to
stand up for me here at home not
consoles will let me go shoot my brother
are some darker people are some poor
hungry people in the mud a big powerful
America is shoot them for what they
never call me near they never let be
there for no dogs will be there Robbie
my nice dolly raped and killed my mother
father
well who shoot them for what I don't
know shoot them little pool of black
people no babies in short or whatever
how can I shootin pool people just take
me to jail he gives it all up he's
willing to give it all up to stand in
solidarity with people in a third-world
country to stand in solidarity with the
Vietnamese people to refuse the
warmongers and at great risk at that
time people were being killed for less
you know right before he takes his stand
and refused and refuses induction into
the army Malcolm X is assassinated then
right after that jaw Martin Luther King
jr. dr. Martin Luther King jr. is
assassinated Robert Kennedy is
assassinated
before that james Meredith ah Medgar
Evers are assassinated so there's death
all around him but he doesn't back down
so he loses his title he loses the money
he loses the spotlight but he gains the
affection and the love of the world and
so and he becomes a galvanizing figure
in the anti-war movement here which is
primarily being led by young white folks
and so Ali he's a hero to the
african-americans especially the poor
and downtrodden african-american masses
in the ghetto he's a hero with the young
whites who will be subsequently become
that the leaders of this nation he's a
hero with the folks of the what was then
referred to as the third world so Ali
becomes a transcendent figure he becomes
just a figure who is loved and and
respected and admired by people
literally all over the world both in
this country and beyond the shores of
this Khan
and then he dedicates his life the
second half of his life as he said to
prepare to meet his Lord I mean how many
people can do that and then allah tala
facilitates that by taking his vitality
taking his voice and so now he can only
turn in and he can focus so you get the
the generosity the charity the courage
the heroic stand in his early life and
then is dedicating himself solely and
strictly to his Lord during his later
life and you put that together you get a
figure that's far far greater than
anything any boxer could be a Joe Lewis
or Jack Johnson or Sugar Ray Robinson or
Sugar Ray Leonard or anyone else you get
a transcending figure that can touch the
lives in the hearts of just multitudes
and billions of people and I think all
that came together and our new brother
Muhammad Ali hundred a lot touch upon
the rabbi who was representing the
Jewish community who Zidane Michael
McRobbie Michael Lerner I come here
speaking as a representative of American
Jews and that we today stand in
solidarity with Islamic community in
this country and all around the world we
will not tolerate politicians or anyone
else putting down Muslims and blaming
Muslims for a few people
what could Muslim celebrities people
were out there have some status you know
some people they get a little bit of
status they changed their name from
Mohammed to mole he actually changed
became a Muslim he was proud he was
proud to be a Muslim right and many
people now they're intimidating nowadays
you know because a lot of the Samba Dali
took his stand in the name of Islam
Google it look when he said my religion
doesn't allow me to go into the army my
religion doesn't allow me to go halfway
around the world and kill people and so
he took his stand in the name of Islam
he defended the name Muhammad Ali and he
embraced it and Ali will walk around
with Dawa pamphlets I autographed our
conference and I think if you're
listening to the speech of Orrin Hatch
was a Mormon he said he got one of those
dollar pamphlets from Ali's only
attracted big big crowds that day in the
as he always did and eagerly gave
everyone autographed pamphlets
explaining his Muslim beliefs hundreds
of Mormons lined up to grab all these
pamphlets and of course I took one for
myself I respected his deeply held
convictions just as he respected mine so
he was very proud and and
unapologetically Muslim and but he was
also unapologetically open-hearted and
unapologetically kind so he combined all
those elements of what what our prophet
sala sellin was all about and I think
one of the things like what my wife is
going to post on Instagram a picture
from the possession and Louisville this
huge sign we love you Muhammad people
all over the world we love you Muhammad
the name Muhammad is on every tongue and
Allah says what I finally Cathy Kroc
we're going to elevate your remembrance
and so everyone is remembering Muhammad
and so Muhammad Ali is just a means but
the end is that everyone is mentioning
Muhammad with love and reverence and
respect so Allah has a
and they love bless us to play our part
what were some of the meritorious deeds
that he did that stood out from the rest
and you can see some people will because
it's good PR you know you did some
charity work and you know some
celebrities did it no but his stood off
from the restaurant over some of these
is charity because he had courage wise
he took that courageous stand people are
dying being assassinated and he stands
up and he takes a stand that people are
being assassinated and killed for less
he saved those hostages didn't eat those
Libre he got he rescued hostages he but
I think is if you wanted and its
associated we talked about this at Juma
courage is the foundation of charity
because the courageous person doesn't
fear the consequences of poverty when
the profits so low I sell him at the
after the battle of hunayn he gave an
acht Robin had this of valley of
livestock and acara he went back to his
people say yeah home s Lee move in the
[ __ ] Yatta Yatta a man lay
yourself alka he went back to his people
he said people become Muslim s Limu
because Muhammad gives like a man that
doesn't fear poverty land [ __ ]
Yatta Yatta men lay Yasha yo shell taka
so Ali was brave and because he was
brave he was generous Ali Ali is said
his charity touched and affected 250
million people a quarter of a billion
people and a lot of that was behind the
scenes chartering planes and bringing
food to Africa giving people on the
street Ali any the fridge just write a
check on the spot they add to his
handlers had to pull him back Ali was
just he had a heart of gold and his
charity was was legendary and I think
that's the key to righteousness because
allah tala reminds us in the quran
lenten el lugar raha hoon few women met
him one at home filming Sheikh in NOLA
happy Helene you will never attain
righteousness and Antonella beer until
you spin from what you love and so ali's
really spent and I think that to me is
the key to the power and the impact in
addition to his courage and his
courageous example heroic example I
think that's the key to making Muhammad
Ali different than any other not just
box or any other athlete not any other
athlete any other person who lived in
the 20th century we're going to keep the
segment short just a couple more
questions how did you feel [ __ ] that not
even 36 hours after this magnanimous
event you know everybody's coming from
every different nationality all these
people come into to them coming together
coming together and get to see really
Islam in a positive light and then you
have this Orlando mass shooting that
happens it just shows that the people
who built this whole so-called jihad
apparatus they still control it and
they're calling the shots and they call
the shots at the times that are most
disadvantageous for Muslims that's just
how I see it and but I think it just
shows that juxtapositions the good
against the evil and it shows the
consequences of the good bringing people
together allowing us to share with each
other to to work towards common goals
and the evil tearing people apart
tearing communities apart generating
anger and hate and bitterness and I
think it just shows us that or reminds
us that we have to be the people of good
we have to be the people of good and we
have to do the kind of good that
Muhammad Ali did and it's not always
easy it wasn't easy for him but if we
can find within ourselves the
wherewithal to bring forth those good
qualities and characteristics of courage
and generosity and magnanimity of spirit
then we will be able to affect this
world in very positive ways despite the
evil actions of the evildoers I think is
significant again we mentioned this at
the juma that amongst the verses that
were recited to to start that memorial
well-attested will hi senator Willis a
yeah good and evil not equal it
viability he
Acin respond to evil with that which is
best good fidelity vena cava bein
wide-awake and the one yamim and you
will see unexpectedly the one between
whom you and he that was great Emma T
becomes as as a war and intimate friend
and so you saw all these enemies become
his friends and that's the power of good
and I think this is a time for for good
there's a lot wrong with the world
there's a lot of suffering in the Muslim
world well we're not going to alleviate
that suffering by imposing suffering on
others you know so I think we're going
to have to be people of good and that
good will eventually vanquish the evil
and the ranks of the good people will
grow and the people will come together
and they'll bring these wars to an end
but when you create that anger and
hatred and bitterness it only fuels the
fires of war and people yeah we got to
get these we gotta wipe discouraged out
got to get these people over there
before they get us over here and that
kind of rhetoric that you see flying
around so I think is really important
especially for our young people who are
can be very emotional and and attracted
to easy quick solutions and and a small
minority who might fall into the the
clutches of these vile and evil people
who are encouraging war or mayhem and
destruction and mass murder and not just
here I mean what happened in Orlando
happens every day somewhere in the
Muslim world what messages blown up or a
Genesis blown up or a marketplace is
blown up somewhere and then this is
unacceptable and and we have to come
together and we have to appeal to our
higher qualities and characteristics to
work to end this scourge and that's when
we will have the credibility and the
moral power to bring these wars to an
end but if you're empowering more
warmongers who are saying carpet-bomb
these muslims newcomb then and you think
that's going to bring an end to the
bloodshed and the suffering of the
muslims is sorely mistaken last question
we're almost
about to break fast we got to go but
Muhammad Ali was reminding people about
purpose he was passing out those
pamphlets educating people out about
Islam he's a modern-day example of
someone who was proud to be a Muslim can
we take that home that he was someone
his name was named after the last and
final mission of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him to get people to motor if
you love Muhammad Ali do you want to
look into the lifestyle the way of life
that motivated him to to live this
absolutely again his foundation was his
faith and we should never dismiss that
as we said when he took the stand that
catapulted him to the ranks of the
Giants he did that in the name of his
religion in the name of Islam and so I
think it's very important for us to look
beyond the hype look beyond the
negativity and see what does this
religion have that can help to create a
giant like Muhammad Ali and many many
others not of that stature but wholesome
upright hard-working loving kind
compassionate but just and firm people
when this situation calls for but never
firmness
that's divorced from fairness firmness
divorced from fairness never that
firmness that's tempered by fairness
justice that's tempered by restraint
love that
that's operationalized by mercy this is
our religion ladies and gentlemen
brothers and sisters this is what we
have to live this what we have to give
this is what we have to share this is
what we must embody and if we can do
that we will make a lot of positive
changes in the world insha'Allah thank
you sir for being with us thank you for
being with us every week we have a new
exciting episode new exciting guess
subscribe if you haven't already we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you assalamu Lee what boy okay
you don't want to miss out you want to
be here every Friday and then we'll try
to give you some short reminders in
between but you can't get that if you're
not coming back to the show every week
Fridays will be releasing it God willing
inshallah subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're going to
be putting out for you thank you peace
be with you
so now Mike